on attend le trophée nous sommes
sûrement pas ça parce qu'ils ont monté
des fois son talent ce soir
[Applaudissements]
ah ah
aujourd'hui le cameroun a gagné ce
penalty
2-2 au mans j'ai jeté dans la mare aux
les camerounais je suis tellement
heureuse d'être camerounaise aujourd'hui
c'est une joie très fier a fait d'être
homo n'est ce pas les liens
et années d'efforts et il va marcher
mais dans les faits le niveau et c'est
vraiment ça plus tout le monde a vendu
quelque intérêt combatif par rapport aux
autres athlètes très combatif tu veux le
match très passionnel est ta moan
développer le football que nous les
spotters en n1 mal entreposées attaquant
vit très performant à avorter vincent
dix et vingt sept équipiers se connaît
et on a su que cette can reste au
cameroun que ce soit contre le mans ou
l'egypte nous avons nous aurons le
dessus et je suis très certain je suis
très optimiste nous irons jusqu en
finale d'après moi le pronostic ou le
prochain match sera de bien 0 je me
retire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ah ah
[Applaudissements]